To make $10 a week more doing something that you don't feel good about
Compared to something you'd feel good about, yeah, make the change you can't
Say i'm gonna
Suddenly become a terribly attractive person when i'm 60 it just doesn't work that way so pick up the right habits now the test
Isn't whether you get the greatest
Does this idea in the world the first time out the test is whether you keep learning as you go along
What your strengths are?
What's that belief nation at seven my?
One word is believe and i believe in you i believe you have an amazing gift inside you that i want to see
Exploded onto the world now i started the meant to me series to try to hang your
Own people who've done a lot, more than us who've accomplished great things and hopefully
By spending a little more time with
Them some of their mindsets their beliefs their way of thinking
Seeps into us to help us become the best version of ourselves so today we're going to learn
From one of the best warren buffett, and five simple yet powerful pieces of his advice mentor me warren
Alright let's kick it off with number one be determined to succeed i would like to tell you of two women, oh?
That each sold the business?
to, berkshire hathaway
To, me actually for many many many millions of dollars
Both of them started with twenty, five hundred dollars by a coincidence was the exact same ahmad it was everything they
Had in the world and one of them
Was a woman?
who landed in seattle in
Couldn't speak a word of english
Had a tag around her neck
The tag said
Fort dodge iowa
The red, cross
Got her to fort dodge where she was reunited with her husband, who would come to the country a couple years earlier
And she lived in fort dodge for two years and as she put it she
Felt like a dummy
She couldn't pick up the language and she couldn't learn a word and so she decided and she and her husband decided
To move to omaha so they came to omaha
in
And there she found a
Small colony of russian jews so she started feeling more at home and then as her oldest daughter, went to school
She would come home this daughter frances and she would teach her mother the words that she learned in school that day and
This, woman rose bumpkin
spent 20 years
Saving money bringing first her siblings over
Her mother and father
Fifty dollars at. A time she sold used clothing to do it
She had four children, during, this period and by
1937 after 20 years
She saved
$2,500
She, went to chicago
And she bought what she put a furniture her dream had always been to open a
furniture store and
This, woman, would never gone to school one day in her life
with
$2,500
But with the same spirit that the people in this room had
About having a dream and working to accomplish that dream
she built a business
Which she sold with me in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in which which did a billion and a half dollars worth of business last, year
The fourth generation, is working in that business
This, woman rose blumpkin
Lived, while she she worked for me until she was 103 and then then i'm not
Said then she retired and she died the next year which is a lesson to all the purchasers managers it
Pretty much her retirement nothing. You can't tell, what's going to happen
but mrs. B
With her $2,500
One further fact about her
She could, not read or write
And she went into a furniture business and she didn't bring anything in unique in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed she
Knew she could outwork, anyone else she knows she cared, about her customers
She worked at murray low
Gross margins but she built this incredible business number two tried to find your passion
Last week honored 60 of them from our burton's south
dakota
state i just
Don't try to find your passion and you know i mean may not find it the first time but you know
Don't sleepwalk through i find something that you really enjoy doing if you can, do it and not you know
Not everybody is lucky enough to be able to find that but it's it ought to be your goal
To, make ten dollars a week more doing something that you don't feel good about
Compared to something you'd feel good about
Yeah, make the change bill said something i thought, was really interesting he said the thing you do obsessively between
Age 13 and 18
That's the thing you have the most chance of being world-class at yeah, they'll said his one thing was coding, what, was your one investment?
No bill and i his father many years ago right after, we met had us a group of about?
20 right down on the sheet of paper one word that they thought accounted for their
Success and bello guy, who may only met twice didn't know, what the other one was writing down?
We both wrote down the same word which was focused and he was focused on?
Software i was focused on investments and it?
It gave me a big advantage to start very young there's no question
About it number three be the person. You, want to be if you look around you at the people you admire
You know they have certain qualities i mean you've got you've got friends, why, do you, like them you know
Generally, you know that they
Generally, they have an upbeat attitude on life generally, they are generous people they're
Humorous, people there are people that do more than their share they're, people that are thinking, about something nice they can do for you
And all those qualities attract
You and none of those are our innate at birth i mean you you can
acquire those and then there's other people to turn you off you know, and
They, have habits they take credit for things they didn't do they
Don't show up on time whatever it may be they're little dishonest about things and
If you're, looking at your life at a young
Age like you are and you can choose what kind of a person you can
Be why, not be the person you admire rather than the person you can't stand it so simple so just write down
The qualities you liked take you to take your five best friends, why, do you
like them and just write down those qualities and you will find there's no quality there that you can't have yourself and
Similarly with the five people you can't stand to be around
put those, put those things down to turn you off about those people and
If they turn you off about them, why should you possess them you can it's so simple
You know it's it's not it's it's, not like it's not like
Some something complicated that you think you should be learning with the best educated. As investing in the stock market
It its enormous ly, important to have people work with you in life they're
Gonna, work with you in life if they like you you know
And they may occasionally i mean if you're in the army or something you know
You, may work for something that you don't like but, by and large
you're, gonna get the best out of people if they feel good about you and
It's just so easy but you've got to develop the habits early because you can't
Say i'm gonna
suddenly become a terribly attractive person when i'm 60 it just doesn't work that way so pick up the right habits now and i
Will guarantee you if you actually just write down those qualities and think about it you will find you can
Have every one of the attractive qualities get rid of the ones that are
Negative and your life will be different number four the light customers henry ford as you may know
Failed twice before he started the ford motor company in 1903 any the the test
Isn't whether you get the greatest
Does this idea in the world the first time out the test is whether you keep learning as you go along
What your strengths are and what you can, do for your customers what you can, bring especially to the party and to do that
You, need, you need a
Genuine a genuine desire day-in, day-out
to
delight the customer
I've never i've never seen a business i've seen a lot of businesses but i've never seen, one that delight the customer
That that doesn't succeed i mean what you want is that customer the next, day?
When they think do i want to rent a car or do i want to buy, some furniture
What goes through their mind you know it's the place, where they've had a great experience
I don't know, what i paid for this?
Type actually probably if somebody gave it to me proof for the purposes of the speech i will
Say i i have no idea but, why, they are the shirt i'm wearing others but i do know, i will remember
How i was treated?
What i bought it i'm with you you long forget about
The price but you never forget whether you had a good experience or a. Porridge furnace
with the purchase experience and number five the last one before a very special bonus clip is
Read i should mention one thing about reading
It was at the library here at columbia, i wish i spent probably more time than any other
Should i love their practical, ii but and i pulled the book out there
Happen to be whose in america and it?
Told me something about
My professor benjamin graham and then i looked up and i went to the library and i said i want to learn more about this
Because i learned this over here
That changed, my, whole life you know, we owned i go now?
because of that
Library, and directing me to some other book
And then following through on that night it's the chance i i read about
One-fifth the pace the bill does but i still spend
Five or six hours of everything i mean it just you can learn so much i particularly love biography just
You know to be able to
Live the lives of these people have been extorted see them so extraordinary the lessons and the you know the discouragements
They, face just everything, about it so i did you, can't get enough of reading
Now i've got a very special warren buffett, bonus clip around, how
Anything can happen in this world that i think you're really, gonna enjoy but before that
My, question of the day is i want to know, what did you learn, today, what did you learn from warren
That you are going to apply somehow to your life or to your business leave in the comments
Below i'm really curious to find out thank you guys so much for watching i believe in you i hope
We continue to believe in yourself and whatever you're, one where it is much love i'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
He is the only person who has ever from scratch
built a company that is in the top ten of the fortune 500
Well berkshire is a holding company of sorts it owns a large number of separate businesses that operate independently
Of each other and to a great extent from the parent company berkshire hathaway
we have maybe 70 maybe 80
Businesses and we ask them to behave in a way that doesn't hurt our reputation at berkshire hathaway but they run, their, own lives
other people do most of the decorating of the office so various things come in
originally when i moved in in
you can see this i went down, to the south omaha library and i think for a dollar i
got seven
copies of old
New, york times from
From big times, like the panic of 1907 this is one?
1929 obviously but i wanted to put on the walls, days of extreme panic and wall street
Just as a reminder that anything can happen in this world i mean it it's instructive art you can call it
ever if you, had to think of one word
That's most important to you or that sums you apple that, would be to like a little beacon
They, believe nation if you, want to know what the most important one word is for tony robbins gary vaynerchuk
Oprah winfrey will.i.am and howard schultz i have a very special secret video for you, check the description for details